samedi soir alessandra sublet connaît
pour la toute première fois la tête du
grand concours des animateurs
cette première la production avait mis
les petits plats dans les grands en
recevant la première dame mme brigitte
macron en tournée en ce moment pour
faire la promotion des pièces jaunes
bonsoir à la cendre à maxi de
m'accueillir une émission qui a été
remporté par grégoire margotton devant 3
millions neuf cent trente huit mille
téléspectateurs soit 27% du public le
détail une odeur plutôt bonne toutefois
le sont dynamiques d'alessandra a hérité
certains internautes qui n'ont pas
manqué de le souligner c'est un merdier
là dedans et variées alors le grand
concours des animateurs
alessandra sublet at elle réussi sa
grande première alors alessandra sublet
at elle réussi sa grande première alors
dit tout si oui sinon aussi vous en
quart et le cul cul la vraie vie tu nous
la vérité
gérad émaillé non alors moi j'ai pas
aimé parce que j'aime beaucoup et
alexandra sublet je la trouve très
sympathique mais je trouve qu'elle a un
côté girl next door un peu hilare un peu
je m'en foutiste elle se marie pour tous
et pour n'importe quoi et du coup sa
ronde et le truc complètement
cacophonique c'est une sorte d'énorme
bordel un énorme capharnaüm est en fait
le problème pour moi d'aller sans
rassurer c'est qu'en fait elle est nulle
part à sa place aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle a quitté un programme qui était
formidable où elle était formidable
c'est à vous elle a été remplacée il
faut dire que à l'elysée avec le moine
l'a balayé d'un revers de manche les
deux sont bien vouloir garder son nom
mais elle était très bien mais son
économie dans ce domaine et
excellentissime les deux mois j'aurais
j'adore j'adore aller sans raison elle a
perdu sa place et depuis fait constater
que c'est très compliqué pour elle et je
trouve que malgré tout on la met là
parce qu'on sait pas où la m et je
trouve qu'elle n'a pas voilà moi elle ne
m'a pas convaincu alors ça a convaincu
bernard montiel animateur sur tf1 le 18
112 à nos jours ça fait par n'importe
qui et je peux vous dire il ya volume
des vestons qu'il était plein
d'autodérision effectivement elle a mal
préparé l'émission y'a des questions
qu'elle ne comprenait pas c'était très
bon enfant
c'était très drôle je trouve j'ai trouvé
son sourire magnifique c'était très
agréable
c'est un vrai bordel ça soufflait dans
tous les sens c'est une spéciale pièces
jaunes
l'intéressé s'est ramassé beaucoup
d'argent n'est pas la question
cit p après si tu t'arrêtes ah oui un
petit peu de csu oui en version us non
mais franchement t'as pas trop la tâche
mois trouve la mission
alors en fait c'est pas tellement de sa
faute c'est que c'est quand même là
trois rennais matrix sur ce jeu la
première était carole rousseau qui pour
moi était la reine coiffés un petit côté
maîtresse d'école un petit peu coquine
beaucoup et il a très bien en place et
les la manche mans le format est fatigué
le casting des balises animateur il ya
plus de ceux de tf1
c'est très dommage et franchement j'ai
pas été couché pas été convaincus manche
heureux et poté convaincu alors c'est
amy chua mais c'est mon jeu préféré est
vacant les deux femmes ont nié temps où
on était ensemble j'avais jamais adoré
alors oui pour le naturel et la
spontanéité et la sympathie pour le côté
manque le côté et rigueur maîtresse
d'école un peu sado maso et puis non
mais je trouve que c'est vraiment de
l'éolienne soufflé par alors j'ai pas
énervé moi aussi alors autant j'adore
elles sont là et moi je trouve que c'est
un autre style justement la porte ton
style elle est plus dans le
divertissement c'est bien aussi mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu à s'assouplir
moment ça a soufflé ce qu'on allait lui
extrait où elle souffle bien sûr qu'on
l'a rien elle est au monde qui les drm
en hausse à tricher trop comme ça je
prends la feuille je déchire tout le
monde rentre à la maison s'est terminée
dans bienvenue chez les ch'tis dany boon
10 1 et 3 et s'il vient vivre dans le
ch'nord 1 il bret deux fois deux îles
bret 3 x 3 il devrait 4 x 4
bref cinq passes en neuf départs fois
resterait deux fois la bonne réponse
était un il vrai de dire que consomment
massivement les spectateurs du tournoi
de wimbledon 3 et fromage à la crème car
à dempsey châssis ropa 3e mandat denis
la bonne réponse et 3 des frais de yale
mot n'est jamais utilisé comme adjectif
aulas a soufflé à droite
non non rien avec les pics c'est qu'on
peut plus réponses étaient quatre salles
c'est vrai que wallace a triché beaucoup
là moi je voudrais vous dire un truc
j'avais pas une bonne réponse assurée
trois bateaux et d'un lâchage tricher de
partout ils ont laissé faire ça c'est
des gens qui seraient ainsi privés pas
dire à quoi tu laisses faire ça tu dis
stop on recommence arrêté de souffler
les réponses de tableaux mois alexandra
sublet j'aime bien dans le grand
concours des animateurs qu'on connaît
pas ou dossier là qu'on arrive et oui
les producteurs qu'adecco rôle est non
mais j'en sais rien mais moi tu laisses
pas fait ça ne me laisse pas bah ça
j'aime bien avec ses paquetages l'armée
dit a pour la toucher mais c'est vrai et
c'est tout le monde souffre comme ça moi
je moi je ne laisserai pas passer ça
j'aime bien sublet après j'aime pas les
missions de ce grand concours des
animateurs qu'on connaît pas ou de tf1
ces sites c'est pareil je connaissais
pas les animateurs ou alors c'est des
gars de chez tf1
moi j'aimerais voir des animateurs je
suis pas patrick sébastien lagaf hanoune
analyse t il à l'époque
pourquoi elles sont pas là les à l'image
d'un jean enfin s'est refermé sur
lui-même
tf1 est en train de se refermer sur
bah ouais mais croyez vraiment que ça à
[ __ ] pour répondre à des questions il
passait pour un tableau sévère si j'ai
une question
parler aux autres cette rue que c'est
pas truqué c'est pas toi que j'ai parlé
je vais parler ses trucs et on sait pas
trop vite et battait une fois c'est pas
trop car j'ai jamais gagné j'ai cet
intrus thema la pente en duel c'est
dommage si demain on fait le grand
concours des animateurs s'est vite si
vous allez me faire gagner vous me
donner les réponses non sur la brique et
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est pas
demain mais un temps franchement je dis
c'est pas un truc ça triche un peu entre
les animateurs voilà on a regardé un peu
bah oui merci je passais trop alors elle
a répondu à alessandra sublet à ses
détracteurs sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'à s'est quand même fait
beaucoup critiqué elle a dit c'est quoi
ces commentaires de coincer et ben moi
j'en fais partie je suis peut-être vieux
jeu vraiment séduit
[Rires]
nous avons envie de jouer et là du coup
j'avais ans je voyais des animateurs
entre qui s'éclatait mais moi je suis
téléspectatrice
j'ai envie de tester aussi ma culture
générale j'ai envie de jouer mais on ne
pouvait rien faire ça s'amuser de les
voir danser et ça se roule par terre et
c'est too much et c'est beaucoup trop et
donc à la rive pas les cadres et
alessandra et c'est ça que j'ai regretté
la mort pas très cosy de l'attendrir
alors c'est vrai que je vous dire c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
dit que sa jolie énorme et oui regardez
on vous a fait une compil j'avais
l'impression d'être dans balance poupe
on a créé les émissions tv gens bien fou
quoi oui c'est sympa je devrai bien mais
je peux pas décider de plus sur le crâne
de fêter un peu d'attention la basque
avec la boccolini vous étiez beaucoup
plus discipliné mi-temps les filles à
l'arrivée ça me désole c'est moi qui
vous ai mis dedans on peut commander on
peut déjà commander le taxi triste
message à mon défaut si c'est possible
qu'elle prépare le passe vite j'en peux
plus je n'en peux plus alors les cherry
et non sur la tête de ma mère l aplomb
je sais pas qui c'est guillaume genton
moi ça me la triche ça m'a pas trop
choqué parce que c'est pour la bonne
cause au rôle en règle générale les
boîtes de production des jeux elles sont
très strict sur la triche personne peut
donner les réponses parce qu'il ya de
l'argent en jeu la personne basse pointe
qui fasse gagner de l'argent et
associations sur sur alessandra sublet
je les aime bien mais son prénom c'est
qu'elle n'arrive pas à marquer de son
empreinte les émissions qu'elle anime ya
plan des missions qu'elle admire on s'en
souvient pas du tout elle anime et
l'amour est dans le pré
elle anime est incroyable talent et je
trouve que là c'est pareil moi pour moi
le grand concours ça restera car le
ruisseau avec l arrêt des styles et et
carole rousseau lundi soir c'est
incroyable rendez-nous kerleroux le
spécialiste inquiet vous étiez sur ces
deux mois de m
moi j'avais pas trop alessandra sublet
mais j'ai découvert
j'ai découvert en roue libre j'ai trouvé
justement quel si j'avais à montaner
qu'elle était que peut-être est en train
de se trouver justement dans un truc
c'est un peu un peu comme ça un peu plus
bordélique donc c'est plutôt bien aimé
ouais c'est tout ce que vous avez à dire
je vais dire ça fait 4 millions
téléspectateurs
ouais c'est sûr on sait alors ce à quoi
je m'attendais sachez qu'ils
s'attendaient un petit peu plus avec la
avec brigitte macouin il s'attendait à
faire à 4 millions en 2005 parce qu'ils
sont diplômés a conquis l'arrivée in and
out in et la tête à brigitte mâcon en
rythme à granville te pousser les zones
30 secondes de brutt a causé semble
maintenant elle est restée trois minutes
mais en début d'émission mis dans le
bain voilà alors là le policier le volet
sans mike hurd vainqueurs des grands
noms qui a fait plus de doute le plus
gagné le concours c'est castaldi c'est
julian lennon judas fois selon
christophe beaugrand quatre victoires et
troisième
mon copain alexandre debanne vidéo gag
où est alors qui est pressenti pour
succéder à alessandra sublet comme
encore pascal c'était juste un coup oui
oui c'est christophe beaugrand nom et
christophe paraît qu'il n'est pas hyper
chaud mais c'est lui il arrive que ce
soit lui mais il est vrai que ce soit
lui avait rien fait de rossini je pense
très très bon succès christophe moi de
ce que je sais il paraît que c'est pas
sûr que les qu'ils veulent ils en train
de réfléchir et du côté pas ts enlevé
ben c'est pas très gratifiant pour elle
par balles à thala veut dire on vous met
là en attendant et puis c'est ce qui est
arrivé avec de nombreux chroniqueurs il
aurait jamais mal pris
désolé on a exactement les mêmes les
mêmes méthodes
justement parlant de mon christophe
beaugrand vous avez vu j'ai eu un flash
/ christophe beaugrand ces derniers
jours je trouve
j'aime beaucoup voilà on s'est parlé ça
je les aime bien incroyable mais je
trouve qu'il est en train d'émerger
accord je trouve qu'il a je vous dis et
je le redis je trouve que je ne trouvais
pas au top il ya 2 ans de 3 ans je
trouvais qu'il y ait là je trouve qu'il
a pris une dimension qu'est ce qu'on
pense nicolas franchement je suis
totalement d'accord et je pense que
c'est l'émission lci qui lui a fait
marrer grossistes à la pause et un
petit-neveu et après tf1 le met en
valeur et a pris une dimension vous
parlait d'aller sans rassembler pour
l'instant alessandra sublet les partout
on enlève déjà ils sont passés avec elle
tant ils sont pas sympas et qu'elle est
là pour installer un animateur faire ce
genre de choses c'est quand même
catastrophique maltraitant les
christophe beaugrand s'installe tout
doucement mais sûrement moi justement l
époque des secret story j'ai mais pas
christophe beaugrand souhait que ce
n'était pas fait pour lui hélas de l'ue
de lover dans une émission politique de
le voir dans un divertissement
je trouve qu'il est plus adapté avec une
tonalité quant à lui donne de la
prestance de la carrure et moi je trouve
de plus en plus beau en plus formaté
j'aime bien ah oui c'est un des seuls
mecs à la télé aujourd'hui qui peut
passer de la télé réalité une émission
d'info un divertissement un jeu et c'est
bien ça semble en fait ouais parce qu à
la télé française on a tendance à mettre
les gens dans des cases starfox effets
de la télé réalité vous pouvez plus
faire marche pas aux classes et bien non
mais c'est pas ce qui se passe
millénaire des gentils et les scieries
sipa mais voilà je l'aimé bien c'est
vrai mais il faut que moi moi c'est pas
ma il faut qu'il progresse encore en
bagarre
il est tombé à nos pauvres badie
physique
je suis moi non plus je pars position
bah moi il a tout pour moi et ma voix
laissant là même les poils comme moi
regarder
mais ça glisse bien il avait
effectivement les mains d'aubry et du
coup y en avait partout mais la rigueur
partout ici ça s'était passé van rouge
en ai vu d'autres
c'est grégoire margotton qui a gagné
donc le grand concours des animateurs
est ce que vous avez été convaincus ou
pas les téléspectateurs tiens oui à 43%
non à 57 % y en a plein qui n'ont pas
aimé vous voyez mais c'est vrai que le
format est fort et sachez qu'on est en
train de travailler sur un quiz un quizz
avec carole rousseau
voilà bien périlleux s'appellera le
petit bac sur ces huit français et voilà
dans le charmant je vous vois bien aussi
faire le test de cuir et de leur faire
avec plaisir charbon le non à l'exemple
ce que benjamin est très bon en jeu
aussi frais bah oui et pas un petit bac
j'avais de beggas tous et des anonymes
se sera pas vous entourent